vous mathieu quelle image qui vous a le
plus marqué en tout cas déjà vegas ça
reste l'un des meilleurs souvenirs
vraiment [ __ ] de notre vie à mes
vrais mandat dit j'espère que pour vous
aussi
je pense qu'on pourra pas leur faire
c'était incroyable vraiment ouais mais
sinon c'était je crois sur les autres
michel parce que forcément c'est mon ami
et campus
au moins il ya un sujet sur lequel il
ment pas c'est ce sont ses attributs
c'est quand il a fait la wii alors je me
rappelle à tout le monde à tous les
niveaux je me rappelle très bien de
cette séquence presque qu'est ce qui
s'était passé
courir à côté c'était un pari où j'avais
parié rigueur non on s'était parlé tous
les douars et evouna il avait une
inquiétude avant j'avais jamais
l'inquiétude que le pantalon descendent
oui parce que j'avais le poids du micro
c'était un pantalon feutrine truc con
75e et vous m'aviez dit j'ai pas de
caleçon
j'ai pas le caleçon et moi et êtes venus
- mais est-ce que tu penses que je mets
un caleçon tout ça et je n'y font rien
au fait tu fais moi confiance ça se
passera bien honnêtement moi j'avais les
cafetières je n'hésite pas à montrer
cette séquence mais voulait pas dit avec
un grand sûr et comme ce nom en reste
comme ça mais jamais de pression je peux
dire le fourbe quand même parce que je
les fais une première fois le gars je
devais faire dix fois dakar se sentent
pattes avant de tomber à le faire dix
fois comme ça je le fais du foie et ça
marche
est ce que je faisais avec un pied léger
sur l'om ça cloche pied et cyril me dit
non mais c'est pas comme ça les règles
les règles d'un corps et j'ai joint
j'ai même pas vu le coup venir je re
commence comme un conte père et ma
séquence savoir que ça marche et j'ai
déjà fait ce coup là la maison des potes
tu sais pas allez c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
tiens de mes plus grands souvenirs de ma
vie j'espère que vous aussi je sentais
qu'ils mais c'est mais j'étais à cette
suite je ne veux pas m'arrêter ait
appuyé deux fois mais il faut que je
gagne quand il est là il est filmé de
profil mais nous laisser derrière elle a
boosté quelque chose c'était très sympa
l'image qui goûte chaque une image
d'isabelle araki vous aviez offert une
heure de conduite en auto école une
voiture un peu particulière vous avez on
avait mis une baignoire au dessus toi
parce que vous détestez prendre de l'eau
sur les cheveux c'est votre annonce est
notre hantise et de ce fait courir et
c'est pas conduire l pendule et donc je
m'en rappelle ça aussi je vous jure je
sais pas pour vous c'est quoi si vous
rappeler de ça j'ai pleuré de rire
allez on y va c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je vous offre votre permis de conduire
vous savez où prévaut le carré
[Applaudissements]
alors isabelle je vous avais encore être
lié à ce que vous avez passé depuis
non jamais mais non et bah faudrait dans
les forêts vous le passez sans rigoler
il ya des gens qui me rappelait mon
dernier chez nous on est chez nous on
est d'accord c'est là oui oui mais quand
alors ce soir j'ai décidé d'être cool
pour les huit ans que tu es pmp isabelle
vous allez rester bien au sec
il n'y aura pas d'eau puisque c'est ce
que vous détestez le plus je vous dis
par contre je sais que vous adorez un
truc que vous aimez les boules
un mélo mais c'est vrai il est belle et
elle adore les boules électro elle adore
le mal elle kiffe le bowling accord donc
on vous a préparé un petit truc
regardez c'est une première mondiale
c'est le bowling de camions vous allez
regarder ce qu'on a un plan voilà
regarder génial ça camions et vous allez
vous devoir du comité pas conduire
arrête de dire que c'est allé signaler
isabella les jeunes et n'a pas non c'est
magnifique c'est un tout à l'heure je
voulais vous faire pour les 8 ans
jamais la ligue merci pour tout
je pêche partie on devrait voir à mon
avis ça va lui plaire
abah abah et ben il se passe un truc
valeriquais les images qui vous a marqué
moi évidemment ils n'ont même pas il en
a parlé c'est mon ami et jean luc
lemoine qui les hantent pandi panda
alors à ce que j'ai eu déjà des gains
déjà avec une perruque c'est tout un
programme
mais jean-luc antec une perruque et la
robe c est de la musique de test on
parle corse était alors ça c'était il
devait arriver chez michou ouais alors
on m'avait dit j'ai pas pu venir à votre
spectacle vous avez joué dans une salle
je croyais une grande salle pour faire
mon spectacle mais je me suis retrouvé
chez michou exactement godard il a été
enseveli exactement il savait pas que
j'aurais il savait pas qu'il allait
faire shooter agoria il savait rien mais
il le mec quand il est sur scène c'est
un art qui n'auraient dessous et de
chômage
ghosn c'est là qu'on voit que jean lui
est un homme de scène heureusement
regarder le ca recule
[Musique]
tu as chanté suffit
[Applaudissements]
jean lui franchement j'ai envie de toi
une question dont les téléspectateurs
aussi qui nous regardent est-ce que ça
reste pour toi parce que je sais que
c'est compliqué pour toi de mettre des
perruques tout ça j'ai l'impression que
ça reste un excellent souvenir et ça me
fait plaisir je pense c'est mon meilleur
souvenir dans l'émission non c'est
vraiment c'est ouf parce que c'est en
plus j'ai été accueilli par les
transformistes qui m'ont maquiller des
to et c'était sur liste parce que
faisant que ce n'était pas des figurants
c'était des vrais touristes qui étaient
là dans le chez michou et ils ont vu
débarquer cet agir sur scène je vois
rien compris il ya mille shocking je
pense qu'ils étaient un petit peu bourré
non mais tu continues à le faire où j'ai
trouvé